hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and right now guys
i'm doing youtube videos because i want
to pass the knowledge i want to
show you guys all the different tools
and techniques that i like to use that
are working for me
and i want to show you how to use it
yourself so if you want to know about
all the stuff and basically how to make
money on the markets you guys are in the
right place
so today i want to make an update on
gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
so i did a few videos guys on gamestop
and i was telling you basically that i
was very bullish that i see the price
action probably going higher
and probably going to 800 but in this
video i want to show you guys
how to use the macd the volume uh trend
lines and moving averages
on the short term to set up your trades
because i think we're going there i'm
gonna do
all the videos on the long term i'm
gonna show you guys how i use a fibs and
iliad
wave theory uh to actually find this
bullish target and to build up my view
so guys don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know
when i upload this new video but today
let's
stay on the short term i am on the
hourly time frame
and guys i want to show you here
how you can actually set up some trades
if you want to capture this
moves up if you are not long yet there
are some beautiful trends
easy threads that you can here do and
make some quick
money so for example first thing is that
you need to spot
some support levels so you can see here
the strong move up that we had from 50
so 50 is a strong
support level on the long term uh and
then
we went to this 175 level
and we corrected all right so for now
the only information you have
is that here we had one two three four
five six
so 10 hours of consolidation around
175 so from then you already know guys
that 175 is the next resistance and that
when your resistance is broken it
becomes support
so then you check what is happening here
on the 8th of march guys
8th of march hourly timeframe what do
you see you have the confirmation
that your level is the right one why
because you have this
breakout through the resistance level
and then we
retest it and we consolidate one two
three
four hours around this level before
blowing up on the upside
so this is telling you that you have 95
percent of chance
that your support level is the correct
one and that you're gonna have find a
lot of liquidity
a lot of support at this level then the
price goes to
350 and what happens guys bam
get destroyed 50 in a matter of
one hour guys this is insane welcome to
the new world
but this is what is happening here you
could have bought it you're right you
know if you are
you know uh you have a buying order
placed at 175 you would have been
executed
we continue what happens then the price
action
reverts goes higher and goes
lower again and yesterday so basically
the whole week was bearish guys that's
that's true uh the whole week was
bearish and once again
one two hours around 175 and we went
higher
so once again guys one 175 has been
has acted as resistance and then support
four times
and in a very uh clean way so you have a
lot of traders that are using this level
and
if if you're using it too you're gonna
have clean reactions
so it's a very nice level to use to for
example enter a trade
and look here you have the 200 period
moving average which is very followed by
a lot of investors
and if the 200 period moving average is
doing something like this
and the price action is doing something
like this guys
again you can have a double signal here
you can buy at
175 stop loss at 160
and try to get this whole move up that
is going to come i believe in it
very soon something else that you guys
can look at
so this is the first thing we are
bullish because we are above the 200 per
moving average we are above 175
so we are bullish i want to show you
guys uh something else that is very
interesting is the volumes
so you can see here i put the volumes
and the whole week was bearish true
the week was bearish but look at the
volumes what did they do
the volumes went lower look at the macd
the macd went lower too
so this is the macd that is here okay so
it's a momentum indicator that is
showing you
the bullishness of the stock you're
watching and you can see that
it's not going higher so basically this
means we don't have any divergence
divergence when you have
opposite information coming from the
price action and a momentum indicator
all the volumes
so it's basically early signals of
reversals
so when you have a reversal so here a
reversal would be
a change in the trend and to start to
be bearish uh you would have here
usually a divergence so you would have
for example the price action going lower
with the volume increasing which means
that when the price
is actually getting sold the volume
increases
this means that actually we have a shift
and that now the bears in control
we don't see it here same for the macd
guys so we don't have
divergence i don't think we're gonna
have this reversal so i think that 175
is going to
hold one more thing you can see guys is
that the
signals uh the signal given by the macd
which is the crossover of the macd and
the nine-day exponential moving average
of the macd itself
that you can see here guys the blue line
and the orange line
the crossover just happened guys on the
hourly time frame
right it's green so it's a bullish
signal on the short term
so i believe that we're gonna have a
bullish open tomorrow
and in terms of targets what can you see
here same thing guys i do my trend lines
as i always do they are
working very well especially on a stock
where a lot of traders are using
technical analysis like gamestop
so you can just draw you connect the two
recent highs that you had
and you have uh here the resistance that
is
surprised at the same level at the 50
period moving average
around 240 250 so
this is the first resistance that you
are going to have so you can buy at 175
i know you guys don't like to sell but
if you want to lock in some profits you
can sell at 240.
i think that we're gonna break this one
so i think we might have something like
this
then we break it we retest and then we
go higher so if you sell here it's fine
because if it goes higher you can still
buy again we're going to have those
three tests we had the retest here
we had the re-test here we had the
re-test here
so we often almost always have this kind
of retest
and then if you sell here by here you
don't lose money you are still
long and you can capture the new move up
without taking the risk of a downside
movement
so this is trading guys so that's it for
me i repeat uh i'm bullish on the short
term
my buying level would be 180 let's say
i would take profits at 240 reload at
240
if we break the 240 250 level and then
i would see what happens at the 480
level but once again guys my view on the
long term is very bullish i think anc or
sorry gme is going
to 800 so guys stay close to shore